was weird
oh you're not wrong about love get ready
for the return of DC's legends of
tomorrow what you want to say you River
ever here has their own journey fair
just taking you on a new path you owe it
to yourself to go starting at 8/7
central on the CW you're really showing
some management attention get off that
demon called your name said you'd soon
be slipping into the dark and I figured
if Emily's demon has you on a first-name
basis you might know something that can
help me save you both I don't need
saving and I am done fighting demons you
think this has something to do with the
demon we're fighting I was speaking of
them metaphorically but yes I did
recently visit the spirit world it's a
long story but it's probably how the
demon knows my name and the demon's name
is Mallis malice smashing very under
demon names just what I need to catch
this mouse one car out now I don't know
what you and your dish a lot of gotten
yourselves into but I suggest you leave
it to the experts oh nice one for the
tip I got a girl to save oh not so fast
you said it yourself this is not just
any demon and we've been fighting it
before you even knew its name and if
this girl's connected Tomales you might
be able to help us destroy him
you wanna tag along for an exorcism yep
that's out of the bloody question of
well we gave you its name so you owe us
well I gave you your soul so you owe me
indefinitely hmm all the more reason for
me to help you dark and his daughter are
just too powerful they have magic that
we don't understand John Constantine the
last time we met I saved your soul now
there's a demon eye where he knows your
name Sarah
there's a war coming
[Music]
and history needs you to be ready
DC's legends of tomorrow all new
episodes return on a new night at a new
time this Monday at 8:00 7:00 central on
the CW hey everybody we got legends of
tomorrow episode 10 coming tonight
Constantine and Wally West are here so
I'll explain you know what's going on
but for the rest of legends of tomorrow
season it's gonna be airing on Monday
nights when Supergirl would normally be
airing hopefully CW has gotten the word
out about that so I believe it's 18
episodes total for legends of tomorrow
if you're just finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos and make sure you click that Bell
to enable alerts just because it's the
Olympics and things are kind of crazy
now so you don't miss any of the videos
there will be a new episode of the flash
ring giveaway when I post my episode
video later tonight what's happening is
is Constantine is coming on tonight
they're going to an insane asylum
because Constantine has found a girl in
need of an exorcism that knows who Sarah
is so there's a connection between them
so it's all connected to the malleus
storyline then we have damian darhk--
reforming a new version of the Legion of
Doom with Grodd his daughter who's
actually played by the real-life wife of
Brandon Roth
Ray Palmer so it's just funny meta stuff
going on when she's on screen beating
the crap out of the heroes but I believe
that Constantine will sort of spill over
into episode 12 they do like a 70s
episode next week and then at the end of
that episode Wally West shows up so in
terms of main cannons storyline we're
talking like episode 13 14 15 16 17 and
18 then he probably goes back to the
flash
they haven't completely spelled out
what's happening later in the season
just because it gets kind of spoilery
and there's a whole bunch of flashes
coming to flash episode 15 the episode
is literally called flash time but I
think that wally west is sitting that
one out because he's still on legends of
tomorrow but there's still be multiple
flashes in that episode in the funny
thing about this constatine arc is that
people were asking matt ryan did you
think that you would come back after the
NBC show was cancelled he's like oh you
know I thought it was nice that they
brought me back for arrow and it was
still in Canon so we're watching the
exact same version of the character they
also have the animated Constantine TV
series that they did a season 4 but they
haven't announced when that's going to
drop that's also canon to the lie back
and TV shows too but here's the thing
everybody wants Constantine to become a
full-time member on the Waverider now
Matt Ryan himself does not have any
other credits on his IMDB right now for
the rest of the year now that doesn't
mean that he's not doing any other
projects because usually that's the
biggest roadblock to bringing an actor
on full-time they're just busy on some
other production everyone that's
involved with the show's said that
they're totally willing to bring him
back when the story merits it obviously
the malice storyline is tied to the
Constantine appearance now so it sounds
like he could totally come back as a
regular next season but they would have
to be a lot of supernatural components
that would require Constantine special
skills because if you don't need an
exorcism you don't need someone that can
work magic then he becomes a relatively
a superfluous character but that also
gets into Wally West - like what do you
do when you have a really powerful
speedster
that hasn't even achieved his full
potential yet like the flash crossover
on arrow last week where Oliver needed
to catch Caden James he was a long ways
away so he phoned up berry berry super
speed ran him and Diggle to catch him on
the highway so I'm already anticipating
a lot of logic questions like you know
if Wally has SuperSpeed how come he
doesn't just solve everybody's problems
so it'll be interesting to see how the
writers on legends of tomorrow handled
that Kenya Lonsdale did say that they're
getting ready to film the last two
episodes of legends of tomorrow so
they're almost done filming the finale
for that the after the place matt ryan
had just said that when his character
comes on to legends he butts heads with
a lot of the characters one because
characters like Ray Palmer have trouble
believing in things like magic even
though he's been on the Waverider with
people that wield the totems so
mysticism shouldn't be that new of an
idea to him but also because he's sort
of a team leader he's a bit of a loner
so usually when he walks into a group he
takes charge and they already have sort
of this group dynamic so he walks in
sort of commands the room and it creates
a little bit of friction within the team
but you guys will see that in tonight's
episode it'll be interesting to see what
he feels like with the current roster
here because they did imply that they're
gonna be cycling the team before next
season and I am pretty confident that
legends of tomorrow will get a season
for the show's interestingly enough have
not all been confirmed for future
seasons I think they're just trying to
see what the ratings are like for the
next couple of episodes
in the middle of the Olympics right now
so only legends of tomorrow and Black
Lightning will be airing new episodes
for the next couple of weeks then flash
an arrow come back and then obviously a
Supergirl will take back its time slot
after legends of tomorrow airs its
finale so I'll just remind people about
the schedule as we go along but I will
do legends of tomorrow episodes while
wally west and constantine are on the
show so everybody just leave your bonus
video requests i know everybody just
wants to see what its gonna look like
when they're all together on screen but
what'll happen is is I have a new black
panther video that I'll post next then
I'll post my legends of tomorrow video
later tonight click here for brand new
flash and click here for brand new
Deadpool thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight